Message three, Sunday, 12:00 AM.
第三条留言，周日，凌晨12点。
Hi Rob, it's Brita. I've had an accident and I'm upside down in my car. I've called 911 and I think the cops are coming. I just want you to know that I'm completely fine except that I'm upside down and hanging from my seat belt because I can't undo it. I'll call you as soon as I get out of here. I love my car. So here I am. Bye.
嗨，罗伯，我是布丽塔。我出了车祸，车子翻了。我已经打了911，我想警察应该快到了。我只是想让你知道，我完全没事，除了我现在是头朝下挂在安全带上，因为我解不开它。我一脱困就会立刻给你打电话。我爱我的车。好了，就这样。再见。
So you're Brita?
所以你就是布丽塔？
I am.
是我。
From the phone message?
电话留言里的那位？
Yes.
是的。
And at the moment when you're making this phone call, you're hanging upside down being held in place by your seat belt. It seems like it would be hard to talk normally.
在你打那通电话的时候，你正头朝下挂着，被安全带固定住。感觉正常说话应该很难吧。
Well, my head was also squashed up against the roof of my car, and it was a really odd position to be in. So I reached my cell phone and called this wonderful woman at the state troopers, and she said, you're upside down in your car? And I said, yeah, but I'm fine. But send a whole bunch of people to get me out of here.
嗯，我的头当时还被挤在车顶上，那姿势真的很怪。所以我够到了手机，打给了州警局的那位了不起的女士。她说：“你被困在翻倒的车里？”我说：“是啊，但我没事。不过多派点人来救我出去吧。”
What happened to Brita is that she was driving her Subaru station wagon about 100 miles from her home in Maine. There was a red SUV parked in the road, just stopped there, dead. She swerved around it, the road was wet, she went into a ditch, flipped over. Her shoulder is still hurt, but basically she's OK.
布丽塔的遭遇是这样的：当时她正开着她的斯巴鲁旅行车，离她在缅因州的家大约100英里远。路中间停着一辆红色的SUV，一动不动。她绕过那辆车，因为路面湿滑，她冲进了沟里并翻了车。她的肩膀受了伤，但基本没大碍。
The most amazing thing you say on this message is that moment where you pause and you just say, I love my car.
你在留言里说的那句话最让人惊讶，就是你停顿了一下说“我爱我的车”的那一刻。
Well, I'm talking about the fact that I've just murdered it and I know that I'm not going to drive it again. And it's a sadness, it's a tragedy for me, to have done this to a car that was perfect its entire existence. It was really horrible.
我是在说，我刚刚亲手毁了它，而且我知道我再也开不了它了。这对我来说是一种悲伤，一场悲剧，因为我竟然对我这辆一直完美无瑕的车做了这种事。那感觉真的很糟糕。
Oh, like it had done nothing to you, it had been perfect and yet, yeah.
噢，就像它从没伤害过你，它一直表现完美，而你却……是的。
And yet, I'd shot it by mistake. Yeah. I did love my car. It was a really great car. It was like a dog. It always did what I told it to do and it never broke down anywhere. I talked to it once in a while. And the new car I pat a lot to tell it it's all right, that I won't do it again. I think we spend more time in our cars in America than anything else, except maybe bed. I think everybody loves their vehicle. And if they don't, they should get rid of it and get something else that they can bond with.
然而，我却失手毁了它。没错，我确实很爱我的车。那是一辆非常棒的车。它就像一只狗，总是听我指挥，从不在半路抛锚。我偶尔还会和它说说话。至于新车，我会多拍拍它，告诉它没关系，我不会再犯同样的错误了。我觉得在美国，我们待在车里的时间比任何地方都多，除了床。我觉得每个人都爱他们的座驾。如果不爱，他们就该换一辆能产生共鸣的车。
Today on our radio show, I Love My Car. We have five stories about feelings between people and machines. Act One, Crunk in the Trunk. In that act, a car stereo so loud it cannot be played in any normal way. Act Two, Baby, You Can't Drive My Car, about a car that broke a man's heart. Act Three, Objects in the Rearview Mirror May be Alarmingly Familiar. In that act, on the roads of Washington, D.C., a man chasing his own car. Act Four, Not Your Father's Chevrolet Salesman, in which we reveal the secret weapon of the number one salesperson at a big Chevy dealer here in Chicago. Act Five, End of the Road, about people who don't want to stop driving no matter what. Stay with us.
今天我们的广播节目主题是“我爱我的车”。我们有五个关于人和机器之间情感的故事。第一幕：后备箱里的“砰砰”声。这一幕讲述了一个音响声大到无法以正常方式播放的汽车音响。第二幕：宝贝，你不能开我的车，关于一辆让男人伤透心的车。第三幕：后视镜里的物体可能令人惊恐地熟悉。这一幕中，在华盛顿特区的公路上，一个男人在追赶自己的车。第四幕：并非你父亲那辈的雪佛兰销售员，我们将揭秘芝加哥一家大型雪佛兰经销商王牌销售员的秘密武器。第五幕：路的尽头，关于那些无论如何都不愿停止开车的人们。请继续收听。
We're going to talk about obsession and subwoofers, and eventually we'll talk about girls and how to get them. But first, we're going to talk about a grudge. Specifically, we're going to talk about Vernon Sergeant and his quest for revenge against his rival, Paul Carmichael. Vernon is a middle aged black guy, Paul's a white teenager from a small town in Pennsylvania. It's a reckoning Vernon's dreamed about for a year.
我们将讨论痴迷和超重低音炮，最终还会聊聊女孩以及如何追求她们。但首先，我们要聊聊积怨。具体来说，我们要讲的是弗农·萨金特，以及他针对宿敌保罗·卡迈克尔的复仇之路。弗农是一位中年黑人，保罗则是来自宾夕法尼亚州一个小镇的白人少年。这是一场弗农酝酿了一年的清算。
We met here at the Mountaineer last September. The last show, he actually beat me pretty good, he actually beat me pretty bad.
我们去年九月在登山者运动场相遇。在那场比赛里，他确实狠狠地打败了我，打得非常惨。
Paul beat Vernon fair and square, but here's what bugs Vernon. There was a glitch in the volume meter at that competition, and in one of the early heats, Paul posted a super high number, the sort of number that only the most monstrous car stereos produce. Someone took a photograph of that moment, Paul apparently crushing Vernon in a head-to-head match, and the photo showed up on Paul's website.
保罗赢得光明正大，但让弗农耿耿于怀的是，那次比赛的音量测试仪出了故障。在早期的预赛中，保罗测出了一个极高的数值，那是只有最恐怖的汽车音响才能发出的那种。有人拍下了那个瞬间——保罗在正面交锋中碾压了弗农——这张照片后来出现在了保罗的个人网站上。
This was placed on his personal web page on dB drag racing. It kind of got under my skin. The reality of it all was he knew that the score was not legit. As far as Paul Carmichael is concerned, our shootout tomorrow, is what I like to call it, is going to be very interesting. Paul is ranked higher in the world. I plan on making up some ground tomorrow.
这被放在了他个人网页的dB直线加速赛专栏里。这让我很不爽。事实是，他很清楚那个分数是不合规的。在保罗·卡迈克尔看来，我们明天的对决——我喜欢称之为枪战——将会非常有趣。保罗的世界排名更高。我打算明天扳回一局。
This is actually the first time I've been to a two-day event and my parents haven't come.
这其实是我第一次参加两天的比赛，而我的父母没来。
This is Paul. As rivals go, he's pretty unintimidating. He just finished high school, he's a little gangly, wears glasses. There's something tech support about him. He's incapable of trash talk, and he's even modest about his own dB drag record.
这就是保罗。作为对手，他看起来一点威胁性都没有。他刚高中毕业，身材瘦长，戴着眼镜。他身上有一种搞技术支持的那种气质。他不擅长喷垃圾话，甚至对自己创下的dB直线加速赛记录都表现得很谦虚。
My first competition I went to, of course I hit 135 decibels.
我参加的第一场比赛，当然，我达到了135分贝。
Was that good, were you pleased with that?
那算好吗？你对此满意吗？
It was terrible. That's like the worst possible score ever. I think I was actually last, the third of three. Of course, I didn't tell anybody that, I just said I came in third.
糟透了。那是有史以来最差的分数。我想我当时确实排在最后，三个参赛者里的第三名。当然，我没告诉任何人，我只说我拿了第三名。
About a decade ago, this car stereo thing got way out of control, to the point where music isn't really part of it anymore. That's right, these systems are too powerful for music of any kind. Walk around the grounds here, a huge parking lot with dozens of guys working in teams, and you don't hear any music except what's coming from the parking lot PA. I asked this one competitor, Dave Jennings, to play me a tune on his system, and that set off a five minute hunt for a CD. He just didn't keep any near his flame-painted Chevy van rigged with a dozen 6,000 watt amplifiers, a dozen subwoofers, and 70 12 volt batteries In a vehicle that weighs more than 33,000 pounds. When he finally found a disk and blasted it through his pride and joy, it was impossible to recognize the tune. It sounded like a rock band underwater.
大约十年前，这种汽车音响比赛变得彻底失控，以至于音乐本身已经不再重要了。没错，这些系统对任何种类的音乐来说都太强劲了。在比赛现场走一圈，你会看到一个巨大的停车场，几十个团队在忙碌，你听不到任何音乐，除了停车场广播里放的那些。我请其中一位选手戴夫·詹宁斯在他的系统上为我播放一段音乐，结果引发了长达五分钟的CD搜寻。他的车是一辆火焰涂装的雪佛兰面包车，装配了十二个6000瓦功放、十二个超重低音炮和70个12伏蓄电池，整车重量超过33000磅。当他终于找到一张光盘并从这件心头好中轰鸣播放出来时，根本听不出那是什么曲子。听起来就像水下的摇滚乐队。
[MUFFLED MUSIC PLAYS]
[闷声的音乐播放]
That's actually Aerosmith. Aerosmith through a stereo that's five tons of bass and not an ounce of treble. In a normal car, it sounds like this.
那其实是史密斯飞船乐队的歌。通过一个只有重低音、没有高音的5吨重音响系统播放出来的史密斯飞船。在普通车里，它听起来是这样的。
[MUSIC - "LIVIN' ON THE EDGE" BY AEROSMITH]
[音乐 - 史密斯飞船乐队的《Living' on the Edge》]
So when the cars line up to compete at a dB drag race and the volts start flowing, nobody reaches for Megadeth. Instead, they use this three-second, electronically-generated tone. They all call it the burp. The idea is to give everyone the same sonic raw material to work with. But the burp is practical, too. Play a whole song on one of these systems and there's a good chance the amplifiers will heat to the point where they burst into flames.
所以当车辆排队参加dB直线加速赛、电压开始涌动时，没人会去选重金属乐队的歌。相反，他们会使用这种三秒钟的、电子生成的单音。他们都称之为“嗝（burp）”。这样做的目的是让每个人都能使用相同的原始声源。而且“嗝”也很实用。如果用这些系统播放一整首歌，功放很有可能会因为过热而烧着。
dB drag racing qualifying rounds brought to you by SPLMAX. Competitors stand by.
由SPLMAX提供的dB直线加速赛排位赛，各位选手请准备。
That's Microsoft Mary, the computerized voice of this competition. A dB drag race looks a little like a regular drag race without the actual excitement of the race part. Two vehicles roll up, side by side, to one of those ready, set, go light trees. You think the cars are about to peel off down the street. Instead, a referee tapes the sound meter inside each car and shuts the door.
那是微软玛丽，这场比赛的电脑语音。一场dB直线加速赛看起来有点像普通的直线加速赛，但少了真正的比赛快感。两辆车并排开到起跑线前。你以为它们要冲上街头，但裁判只是把分贝仪贴在车内，然后关上车门。
Ready, set, go.
准备，就绪，开始。
The competitors stand outside their vehicles with these on/off switches attached through a wire to their stereo. And when the race starts, they've got 30 seconds to burp their machines.
选手们站在车外，手里拿着通过电线连接到车载音响的开关。比赛开始，他们有30秒的时间来让他们的机器发出“嗝”声。
[DEEP BUZZING]
[低沉的嗡嗡声]
That's the burp heard from outside the car. Moments later, the volume reading for each racer is posted on a tote board overhead. The winner proceeds to the next round, tournament style.
这就是从车外听到的声音。片刻之后，每个选手的音量数值会发布在头顶的记分牌上。胜者进入下一轮，采用锦标赛形式。
Winner, 151.5 dB.
胜者，151.5分贝。
What's measured here is decibels, but everyone calls it SPL, short for Sound Pressure Level. At these volumes, noise is a lot like a violent gust of wind, so dB drag racers do everything possible to stiffen and seal up their vehicles to prevent sound pressure and noise from escaping. It's an engineering problem. How do you build a stereo that's as loud as a riot in a car so perfectly sound proofed that you can't hear anything inside it? Doors are clamped shut, walls are often reinforced with poured concrete, the interior is dismantled, the seats and dashboard are ripped out. There's barely room for one person to fit inside. You end up with what is basically a huge mobile speaker box juiced by dozens of car batteries. It's a rolling vault of noise, like a tank designed at Ozzfest. But there are limits.
这里测量的是分贝，但大家都叫它SPL，即声压级的简称。在这种音量下，噪音就像狂暴的风暴。所以dB直线加速赛选手会竭尽全力加固并密封车辆，防止声压和噪音泄露。这是一个工程难题：如何在完美的隔音车厢里制造出足以媲美暴动现场的音响效果？车门被紧紧锁住，墙壁通常用混凝土浇筑加固，内饰被拆除，座椅和仪表盘都被剥掉，里面几乎没有容纳一人的空间。最终的结果基本上就是一个巨大的移动扬声器箱，由几十块汽车电池供电。它是一个移动的噪音金库，就像奥兹音乐节（Ozzfest）上设计的坦克。但这也是有限度的。
We want cars that have a shape of a car, have a function of a car. Our rules state that the car has to be driven into the competition.
我们要求车辆必须保留汽车的形状和功能。我们的规则规定，车子必须是自己开进比赛场地的。
How far do you have to be able to drive the car?
你必须能把车开多远？
We usually require the competitor to drive the car 20 feet.
我们通常要求参赛者能把车开动20英尺。
20 feet. This is Sam Horn. Yes, that's his real name. He's been judging dB drag races for years. He says most people trailer their cars to the event.
20英尺。这是萨姆·霍恩。是的，这是他的真名。他担任dB直线加速赛裁判多年。他说大多数人都用拖车把车运到现场。
Most of these guys have modified everything for maximum performance on the stereo, so there's no gauges, the windows have been replaced with armor plating, there's no air conditioning, there's no ventilation. I mean, there's nothing in there except the steering wheel and a gas pedal. but a lot of times, the steering wheel takes up way too much space so they'll chop it and put whatever they can find in there. I've seen golf club heads, beer taps. One guy used a half a speaker, just so they could try to steer the car.
这些家伙大多为了音响效果最大化改装了一切，所以车里没有仪表，车窗换成了装甲板，没有空调，没有通风装置。我的意思是，除了方向盘和油门踏板，什么都没有。但很多时候，方向盘占的地方太大了，他们会把它切掉，换上任何他们能找到的东西。我见过高尔夫球杆头、啤酒龙头。有个家伙甚至用了一半扬声器，只是为了能控制方向。
Obviously, these things aren't built with passengers in mind. In fact, one of the ironclad rules at a dB drag race, you're not allowed in a car when it's show time. The sound pressure in any dB dragger at full power will make you sick.
显然，这些东西在建造时根本没考虑乘客。事实上，dB直线加速赛铁律之一就是：比赛时禁止待在车里。dB直线加速赛赛车在全功率下的声压会让你呕吐。
At that point you start suffering problems with your vision, nausea. So for safety, we have them operate their vehicle outside at anything above 110 decibels.
到那个程度，你开始视力受损、恶心。所以为了安全，任何超过110分贝的操作都必须在车外进行。
So how loud are these things? Reach over to the volume control of your radio right now. Got it? In a second, I'm going to play you a dB drag racing signal tone. So turn it all the way up now.
那么这些东西有多响呢？现在伸手去调节你收音机的音量控制。调好了吗？一会儿，我要播放一个dB直线加速赛的信号音。现在把它调到最大。
[DEEP BUZZING]
[低沉的嗡嗡声]
Now take this sound and, if you can possibly imagine this, multiply it by five. A typical dB drag racer is many times louder than the front row of any rock concert you've been to. Lore has it that these systems can crumple paper, that you're better off standing next to a jet engine than in a dB drag racer with the windows up. Some of this is true, but the guy who created this league, Wayne Harris, says some of it is macho myth.
现在拿着这个声音——如果你能想象的话——乘以五倍。典型的dB直线加速赛赛车比你参加过的任何摇滚演唱会的第一排都要响得多。传说这些系统能把纸震碎，待在关着窗的dB直线加速赛赛车里，还不如待在喷气式发动机旁边。有些是真的，但创建这个联盟的韦恩·哈里斯说，其中一些只是大男子主义的虚构故事。
I've heard people say that if you sit in these vehicles it will kill you. That's not the case. They'll sit in there, tweaking their vehicles. Of course, they wear hearing protection. But it's not going to stop your heart or cause you to disintegrate or anything like that.
我听过有人说待在车里会致命。那不是真的。他们会坐在里面调试车辆。当然，他们会戴护耳装置。但它不会让你的心脏停止跳动，也不会让你分崩离析。
If you want to know how all this dB drag racing madness started, Harris is your man. It goes back to when he was a college kid in the '80s looking to meet babes.
如果你想知道所有这些dB直线加速赛的疯狂是怎么开始的，哈里斯是最佳人选。这得追溯到80年代，他还是个想结识女孩的大学生的时候。
If you have something that everybody just thinks is really, really cool and wherever you go, a crowd of people gather around, the girls want to be with that person.
如果你拥有一些大家都认为非常非常酷的东西，无论你走到哪里，都会有一群人围过来，女孩们也想和那个人待在一起。
Harris should know. he began his car stereo career by building the Terminator, which was a 1960 Cadillac hearse he tricked out with a 30 inch subwoofer-- the kind you find at rock concerts-- 52 other speakers, six amplifiers, and a dashboard retooled to look like the cockpit of a jet. When he played Van Halen, he says you could hear it coming a mile away.
哈里斯很清楚这一点。他开启他的汽车音响生涯是靠建造“终结者”，那是一辆1960年的凯迪拉克灵车，他改装了一个30英寸的低音炮——你在摇滚演唱会才能见到的那种——52个其他扬声器，6个功放，还有一个仪表盘重新改装得看起来像喷气式飞机的座舱。他说当他播放范·海伦乐队的歌时，一英里外都能听见。
I would wear earplugs and then over that I would wear earmuffs, like shooters use when they go to the shooting range.
我会戴上耳塞，然后在外面再戴上耳罩，就像射击运动员去靶场时用的那种。
Did that not seem slightly insane at the time, to build a car stereo so loud that in order to sit in the car and play it, you had to have ear plugs and earmuffs?
当时不觉得有点疯狂吗？造出一个音响声大到为了待在车里播放，你还得戴上耳塞和耳罩？
Yeah, it was kind of weird because-- it was kind of cool though, because people would see you wearing these headphones and they already knew that you had a pretty loud stereo but then you're reinforcing that concept because they're actually seeing you in your own car wearing headphones. So yeah, it was pretty nuts. When I think back about it now, yeah, it's pretty crazy.
是啊，确实有点怪，不过……但也挺酷的，因为人们看到你戴着这些耳机，就已经知道你的音响很响了，但你亲自在车里戴着耳机，进一步强化了这一概念。所以，是啊，这确实很疯狂。现在回想起来，确实太疯狂了。
[MUSIC - "JUMP" BY VAN HALEN]
[音乐 - 范·海伦乐队的《Jump》]
He and a couple of his friends started competing to see whose system was the loudest. And pretty soon, they discovered that if you just want to make a decibel meter jump, music is not very efficient. So they invented the burp. That was 1995. The dB drag racing league Harris founded today claimed more than 10,000 competitors. And last year, it staged more than 300 races, or whatever you call these things. You build up points at each event, just like NASCAR. And if you're good enough, you're invited to the national championships in Tennessee.
他和几个朋友开始比谁的系统最响。很快他们发现，如果你只是想让分贝仪跳动，音乐并不是最高效的。所以他们发明了“嗝”。那是1995年的事。哈里斯创立的dB直线加速赛联盟今天宣称拥有超过10000名选手。去年，它举办了超过300场比赛，或者无论你管这些叫什么。你就像纳斯卡赛车一样在每场活动中积累积分。如果你表现够好，就会受邀参加在田纳西州举行的全国锦标赛。
There are celebrities. I've seen the competitors and the judges signing peoples' shirts, their hats, their equipment, their amplifiers in their car. I've seen people signing the vehicles themselves. Any time somebody makes it to a level where they're actually a world record holder, in our world-- it's our world-- then everybody's going to know who they are.
这里有明星。我见过参赛者和裁判在人们的衬衫、帽子、装备、功放上签名。我甚至见过有人在车身上签名。任何时候，只要有人达到世界纪录保持者的水平——在我们这个世界里，这是我们的小世界——每个人都会知道他们是谁。
I've been to a couple of these now, and I'm always stuck with the same question. Why? Why, oh why, oh why? It's not prize money. There's hardly any in it. And it's not women, there aren't any at these things. There aren't even spectators, unless you count other competitors plus the few glum relatives who appear to have been taken here against their will. My best guess is that it's all about the quintessentially American obsession with glory, however fleeting. Everyone wants to be the king of the hill. That's international. But the number of aspiring kings always dwarfs the number of available hills. So in this country, we build more hills. We're geniuses, in fact, at building more hills.
我现在已经参加过几次了，我总是被同一个问题困扰。为什么？为什么，哦，为什么？不是因为奖金，因为奖金少得可怜。也不是为了女人，因为这里根本没有女人。甚至连观众都没有，除非你算上其他选手，以及那些看起来被迫被带到这里的苦着脸的亲戚。我的猜测是，这完全是关于那种典型的美国式对荣耀的痴迷，无论它是多么短暂。每个人都想成为山丘之王。这是全世界共有的心态。但渴望成为国王的人数总是远多于可供争夺的山丘。所以在这个国家，我们建造更多的山丘。事实上，我们在建造更多山丘方面简直是天才。
We've got a league for everything, including underwater hockey and lawn mower racing. That's dB drag racing. It's utterly pointless. A car stereo competition with cars you can't drive and stereos you can't listen to. Until you realize that it allows a group of people to call themselves the best in the world at something.
我们什么都有联赛，包括水下曲棍球和割草机赛车。这就是dB直线加速赛。它完全毫无意义。一场让你没法开的车和没法听的音乐组成的汽车音响比赛。直到你意识到，这让一群人能够自称在某件事上是世界第一。
We need that car shut off in lane two.
我们需要第二车道那辆车关掉。
It's mid-afternoon on Sunday. Time for Paul and Vernon's showdown. Paul looks worried. His system is acting a little flaky.
周日午后。保罗和弗农决战的时刻。保罗看起来很担心。他的系统表现得有点不稳定。
I changed the frequency, changed the volume, it just gets lower. I tried testing it, it's not doing anything different. So I'm just going to let it charge and go up there, give the best I've got, and probably lose.
我改了频率，改了音量，但声音反而更小了。我试着测试了一下，没有任何变化。所以我打算让它充电，然后上场，尽我所能，然后大概率会输。
Street three. Lane one, Paul Carmichael. Lane two, Vernon Sergeant. Competitors stand by.
街道三组。第一车道，保罗·卡迈克尔。第二车道，弗农·萨金特。选手请准备。
I just need to get a thumbs up, ready in lane one from Paul Carmichael. Thumbs up in lane two, Vernon. Watch the leader board, here we go.
我只需要得到一个确认，第一车道的保罗准备好了。第二车道的弗农也确认。盯着记分牌，我们要开始了。
Paul and Vernon are each laying on top of their cars, their bodies acting as human sound baffles.
保罗和弗农分别趴在他们的车顶上，他们的身体充当了人体声障。
Ready, set, go.
准备，就绪，开始。
[DEEP BUZZING]
[低沉的嗡嗡声]
51.6 in lane two.
第二车道是151.6。
Vernon burps first, posting a 151.6 decibels. Then he stands back looking pleased and waits. Paul does nothing for a very long 20 seconds. This might be a psych out or it might be tactics. If Paul holds out to the last moment and his score is higher than Vernon's, Vernon won't have time to burp again in the 30 second window. Paul is just standing there.
弗农先发声，打出了151.6分贝。然后他站在后面看起来很满意，等待着。保罗在漫长的20秒里什么都没做。这可能是心理战，也可能是战术。如果保罗等到最后一刻，分数比弗农高，弗农就没有时间在30秒内再发声了。保罗只是站在那儿。
10 seconds.
10秒。
With five seconds left, he finally moves.
还有5秒时，他终于动了。
[DEEP BUZZING]
[低沉的嗡嗡声]
Five, four, three, two, one.
五，四，三，二，一。
50.8.
50.8。
Time.
时间到。
And Vernon Sergeant is our winner in street a. Way to go Vernon. Paul Charmichael, great run.
弗农·萨金特是我们街道组的胜者。干得好，弗农。保罗·卡迈克尔，跑得很棒。
Paul posted 150.8, nearly a decibel less than Vernon. Paul looks pretty devastated. He says later that he held off till the last second just to entertain the crowd. Vernon, meanwhile, is doing a dB drag race equivalent of an end zone dance.
保罗测出了150.8，比弗农低了近一分贝。保罗看起来很沮丧。他后来解释说，他等到最后一秒只是为了娱乐观众。与此同时，弗农正在进行dB直线加速赛版本的达阵舞。
Yeah, we spanked that ass. It wasn't a default. It wasn't fake, it wasn't artificial. I beat him fair and square.
没错，我们狠狠地教训了他。这不是违规，不是假的，也不是人为的。我赢得光明正大。
As the competition wound down, there was a lull in the action and I couldn't resist. I drove my rented Chevy Cavalier to the competitors' lanes, and Sam hooked up the volume meter while I revved the engine a couple times and threw the official dB drag race CD into the stereo. Then I cranked the dial and played that signal tone as loud as I could. 124 dBs. Sam was giggling. It was the smallest number he'd ever seen in his entire career. And I'm not going to lie to you. That made me a little proud. I was the lowest of the low, of all time, may be in the whole country, possibly in the whole world. And nobody can take that away from me.
比赛接近尾声时，现场有一阵空档，我忍不住了。我把租来的雪佛兰卡瓦里开进参赛车道，萨姆接上了音量计，我猛踩了几下油门，把正式的dB直线加速赛CD塞进音响。然后我把旋钮拧到最大，尽可能响地播放那个信号音。124分贝。萨姆在咯咯笑。这是他整个职业生涯中见过最小的数字。我不会骗你，这让我有点自豪。我是史上最低分，可能是全国，甚至全世界最低。没人能夺走这份荣誉。
David Segal of the Washington Post.
《华盛顿邮报》的大卫·西格尔。
I really wanted it to be a good car and I spent all my money, and I started meeting other people who knew cars, who were telling me all the things that were bad about it. And that made me feel really bad, so I--
我真的很希望它是一辆好车，我花光了所有的钱。后来我开始结识其他懂车的人，他们一直在告诉我这车哪儿不好。这让我感觉真的很糟，所以我……
Oh my god, like you married the wrong person.
噢我的天，就像你嫁错了人一样。
Yeah, like all my friends think my wife is a jerk.
对，就像我所有的朋友都觉得我老婆是个烂人。
Did you ever try to get a girl with that car?
你有没有尝试过开那辆车去泡妞？
I had really high hopes for the MGA. I was sort of still figuring out how to talk to girls and things like that, and I guess I was 17 and I had this job delivering chicken for this place called Chicken Holiday or something like that. But there was this girl there that I'd had a crush on since the sixth grade. I was convinced that when she saw this car and me in it, she would realize that I was the take-charge kind of guy that she had always been looking for.
我对这辆MGA抱有很高的期望。我当时还在摸索怎么跟女孩说话之类的。我想我那时17岁，在一家叫“鸡肉假日”之类的地方送外卖。店里有个女孩，我从六年级就开始暗恋她了。我确信，当她看到这辆车以及我在车里时，她会意识到我就是她一直在寻找的那种掌控型男人。
Somehow, I managed to ask her out for a date, so I went to go pick her up in this car. And I rolled up in front of her house and the car is belching and farting and making bad noises and I grind the gears, inexpertly shifting it. And she comes out of her house and just starts laughing and laughing at it. I thought she was laughing at me, but she was really laughing at the car. And the rest of the date was just bad.
不知怎的，我居然约她出来了。我开着车去接她。我把车停在她家门前，车子直打嗝、放屁，发出刺耳的噪音。我不熟练地换挡，磨损着齿轮。她从屋里出来，就开始疯狂地大笑。我以为她在笑我，但她其实是在笑那辆车。那次约会剩下的时间简直糟透了。
I'm surprised that you kept the car after all these disappointing experiences.
我很惊讶你在经历了这么多失望之后还留着那辆车。
Yeah, well that's the stern metal I'm made of, I guess. I don't know.
嗯，这就是我的倔强吧，我想。我不知道。
I'm surprised that you've gone on to have seven of them in all.
我很惊讶你最后总共买了七辆。
Yeah, you're in a reality-based world, Ira. I'm faith-based and it's an article of my faith that there is no cooler car than the MGA.
没错，艾拉，你活在一个以现实为基础的世界里。我则是以信仰为基础，而我的信仰准则就是：没有比MGA更酷的车了。
So right now, you're a car tester, and that means-- just explain the procedure. You get a car every week?
所以现在，你是一名汽车测试员，这意味着……解释一下流程吧。你每周都能拿到一辆车？
Yeah, right now at least one car every week gets brought to my house, and often I write about them and sometimes I don't, and sometimes they just sit there and I look at them.
对，目前至少每周有一辆车送到我家。我通常会写关于它们的文章，有时不写，有时它们就停在那儿，我就看着它们。
And is it like being a rock critic where most of the CDs that a rock critic will listen to just are not that interesting, they're just all kind of bland? And so most of the cars that you're driving just aren't that interesting?
这就像做摇滚乐评人吗？大多数乐评人听的CD其实并不那么有趣，都很平淡。所以你开的大多数车也不怎么有趣？
Yeah. It's not they're bad, it's just that they're not very interesting. Mediocrity is a relative thing, and as all cars get better, it takes more for cars to stand out. And it is very much the truth that all cars are better. In the 1960s and '70s, you could buy cars that would kill you if given half a chance. They handled treacherously or they would break. That was the other thing, is that there were cars that were famous for blowing up, which is one of the reasons I like old cars, because catastrophic malfunctions are still very much on your menu. Which is exciting to me, but I understand that that's not what the general market likes.
是的。不是它们不好，只是没那么有趣。平庸是相对的。随着所有汽车的性能都在提升，让车子脱颖而出变得更难。事实确实是所有车都在变好。在60和70年代，你买到的车稍不留神就会要了你的命。它们操控极度危险，或者容易坏掉。这就是我喜欢老车的原因之一，因为灾难性的故障仍然在你的“菜单”上。这对我来说很刺激，但我明白大众市场不喜欢这样。
So the net effect of it is that cars just keep getting better and better, but the average car today is so much better than the best car was 10, 20 years ago or, god forbid, 40 years ago, that you can't really even have any fun in them.
所以最终结果就是，汽车变得越来越好，但今天平均水平的车比20年前，或者天哪，40年前最好的车还要好得多，以至于你根本没法在它们身上找到乐趣。
The fact is that modern tires, they used to be like glorified bicycle tires, and now they're a foot and a half, two feet wide. They stick to anything. And the brakes are unbelievable, they come out of supersonic transports and they'll slow you down in a jiffy. What the enthusiast always liked doing, what sports car people in the 1950s would dream of was sort of sliding around corners and controlling the car as you went sideways through a turn. And that was a stock in trade, and all people who were interested in cars learned how to drive sideways.
事实是，现代轮胎——以前它们就像美化过的自行车轮胎——现在有一英尺半、两英尺宽。它们能黏住任何东西。刹车更是不可思议，它们的技术源自超音速运输机，能瞬间让你停下来。汽车发烧友以前喜欢做的事，50年代跑车车主梦想的事，就是在弯道侧滑，在侧身过弯时控制车辆。这是当时的基本功，所有对车感兴趣的人都学会了如何侧滑驾驶。
Now you have to be going 90 miles an hour to get sideways because your tires are so big, just for one reason. And your suspension is so sophisticated that to have fun that way, it's much harder for people. And when it does happen, they're going too fast.
现在，你必须以时速90英里行驶才能实现侧滑，仅仅是因为轮胎太宽了。而且悬挂系统太精密了，要以那种方式获得乐趣，对普通人来说难得多。当它真的发生时，速度已经太快了。
But what you're saying is that what makes a car fun is an element of danger.
但你是在说，让车好玩的是危险因素。
I think that's part of it, but it's also the mastery of man over machine.
我认为这是部分原因，但也是人类对机器的掌控感。
Right, right, right. Because if the machine basically does it all for you, then there's no fun in it for you.
没错，因为如果机器基本上为你做了一切，那你自己就没乐趣了。
Yeah, there's not a lot of skill involved, which is why I have to say that on the same 55 mile an hour roads, when I get in my '59 Morris Minor, I can be sideways at 12 miles an hour going around a turn. I never have to break the law, nobody even knows that I'm driving at the absolute limit of my ability.
对，没太多技术含量。这就是为什么我必须说，在同样的限速55英里的公路上，当我开着我的59年莫里斯米诺时，我可以在时速12英里过弯时侧滑。我永远不需要触犯法律，甚至没人知道我正在发挥我驾驶能力的极限。
Jamie Kitman, the New York Bureau Chief for Automobile Magazine, US editor for Car Magazine, and a writer for GQ. Coming up, car salesman smackdown, hustle versus bustle, Great News Tim and his nemesis, with opposite tactics, opposite strategies to sell you a car. That is all in one minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
杰米·基特曼，《汽车杂志》纽约分社社长，《汽车杂志》美国版编辑，《GQ》撰稿人。接下来，汽车销售员大混战，推销与忙碌，好消息蒂姆和他的宿敌，用截然不同的策略卖车给你。这一切将在下一分钟呈现。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
Darren is my older sister's fiance and for a long time, he drove a white 1990 Toyota Camry. It had a vertical dent on the trunk and a tow ball on the back. One afternoon two years ago, he went to where he thought the car was parked near his apartment in Washington, D.C.
达伦是我大姐的未婚夫，很长一段时间里，他开着一辆白色的1990年丰田凯美瑞。后备箱上有一个纵向的凹痕，后面还有个拖车球。两年前的一个下午，他去了他认为车停在华盛顿特区公寓附近的地方。
The car was nowhere in a one block radius of our apartment, and so I rode my bike around in the January rain, I rode my bike around in concentric circles around for about eight blocks. Then it became clear that it was just nowhere, anywhere, and so I reported the car stolen. I mostly just thought, I'm never going to see my car again. That's what the police had told me, also.
在他公寓方圆一街区内，车根本不见踪影。所以我骑着自行车在1月的雨中转悠，围着公寓转了好几个八街区的大圈。后来很明显它哪儿也不在，所以我报了警说车被偷了。我当时想的主要是：我再也见不到我的车了。警察也是这么跟我说的。
What did they say to you?
他们对你说了什么？
He said that most likely, it was some teenage kids who had taken it out for a joy ride and that either would drive it until it ran out of gas, and then they would leave it, or maybe they would just drive it out of the city somewhere and dump it in a river or something.
他说很可能是些青少年把它开出去兜风了，他们要么会一直开到没油，然后弃车，要么就是会把它开出城市扔进河里之类的。
Darren's insurance company paid for a rental car, which he drove around for a couple days. He started thinking about what kind of car he'd buy next. One evening, he drove the rental over to a friend's house to watch a football game.
达伦的保险公司支付了一辆租来的车，他开了几天。他开始考虑下一辆车买什么。一天晚上，他开着租来的车去朋友家看球赛。
It was either a Sunday or Monday, one of the Sunday or Monday night football games. And I turned the corner onto their street, and at the stop light in front of me, about a half a block up was a white Toyota Camry with a vertical dent on the trunk and a tow ball and it was my car that was in front of me. And there were four people sitting in the car driving it. And so I never actually went into my friend's house, but I stayed in my car and started tailing them, thinking that I would be able to figure out how to get my car back.
那天是周日或周一，周日或周一晚上的橄榄球比赛之一。我转弯进入他们的街道，就在我前面的红绿灯处，半个街区远的地方停着一辆白色丰田凯美瑞，后备箱有纵向凹痕，还有个拖车球。那是我的车，就在我前面。车里坐了四个人在开。所以我根本没进朋友家，而是待在车里开始尾随他们，心想我能想办法把车拿回来。
Of course, retrieving your car while it's being driven by thieves can be a little complicated. Darren realized he'd need backup.
当然，在小偷驾驶的情况下收回你的车可能有点复杂。达伦意识到他需要支援。
This is 911 Dispatcher 6360.
我是911接线员6360。
He called 911.
他拨打了911。
Hello.
你好。
My name is Darren [UNINTELLIGIBLE], and my car was stolen while I was on vacation. And I filed a police report. I'm right now driving in my rental car, and I was driving around and I'm right now following my car that was stolen.
我叫达伦，我度假时车被偷了。我已经报过案了。我现在正开着租来的车，我在路上开车，我现在正在跟着被偷的那辆车。
Heading in which direction?
往哪个方向？
Listening to this tape, you realize 911 people really have heard everything. The operator snaps to action so matter-of-factly that it seems like maybe she gets this all the time. At a certain point, Darren wants her to acknowledge that these circumstances are a little special, right?
听这段录音，你就会意识到911的接线员真的什么都听过。接线员处理得如此例行公事，以至于好像她经常遇到这种情况。在某个时刻，达伦希望她能承认这些情况有点特殊，对吧？
I can't believe they were driving my car around my neighborhood.
我真不敢相信他们竟然开着我的车在我的社区里转悠。
Not too bright.
不太聪明。
Not too smart at all.
确实一点都不聪明。
Police have been dispatched, where are they now?
警察已经派出了，他们现在在哪？
We're still on Pennsylvania, we're just about to cross the river.
我们还在宾夕法尼亚大道上，正要过河。
It goes like this for a few minutes. Darren driving through the dark, cold D.C. streets at about 30 miles per hour, both the victim and potential hero in this chase, giving the 911 woman frequent updates on their location.
就这样持续了几分钟。达伦在寒冷阴暗的华盛顿街头以大约每小时30英里的速度行驶，既是受害者，又是这场追逐中潜在的英雄，不断向911接线员更新他们的位置。
I was assuming that any minute, some cop cars were going to fly up behind us. But in actuality, I passed at least two precinct stations with parking lots filled with police cars but nobody coming out after me. And the whole time I was on with 911, on with this woman, and she was just, I have an APB out, if they're available, they'll come. So I just kept following them. And then we did this big U-turn on Pennsylvania Avenue. They're headed right on Pennsylvania-- oh, they turned around on Pennsylvania headed towards Maryland.
我当时以为随时会有警车飞驰而至。但实际上，我经过了至少两个警察局，停车场停满了警车，却没一个人出来追我。我一直在和911通话，和这个女人保持联系，她只是说，我发出了全城通缉，如果他们有空，他们会来的。所以我只能继续跟着。然后我们在宾夕法尼亚大道做了一个大掉头。他们正朝着宾夕法尼亚……噢，他们在宾夕法尼亚转过头往马里兰方向去了。
Where? What's the last street?
哪儿？最后的一条街是什么？
They're on Pennsylvania and Potomac right now. Should I keep following them?
他们现在在宾夕法尼亚和波托马克。我该继续跟着吗？
Yeah, but stay a safe distance, of course.
可以，但当然要保持安全距离。
At this point I knew that they had to know I was tailing them because nobody is doing U-turns following them on Pennsylvania Avenue. But at this point, I was angry and filled with adrenaline, so I was ready to keep going. And actually as they were running the red light, I thought, well maybe the thing to do is just to gun it and smash into their rear end, figuring that, whatever, the insurance company's going to pay for any damage. But if I smash into them, then at least they're stuck.
那时候我知道他们一定知道我在跟踪，因为没人会在宾夕法尼亚大道上跟着车做掉头动作。但当时我很生气，肾上腺素飙升，所以我准备继续追。事实上，当他们闯红灯的时候，我想，也许该做的就是猛踩油门撞上去，反正保险公司会赔偿所有损失。但如果我撞上他们，至少他们被困住了。
And then presumably, there are four of them, there's one of you. There might be some kind of scuffle or something.
而且大概率车里有四个人，而你只有一个。可能会发生某种冲突之类的。
I obviously hadn't thought this whole thing through.
显然我没把整件事考虑周全。
They're headed towards the Anacosta River on Pennsylvania Avenue right now. They just ran a red light. I might have lost them. They ran that red light, I can't tell if they went south on Minnesota or if they went straight on Pennsylvania.
他们现在正沿着宾夕法尼亚大道朝阿纳科斯蒂亚河方向开。他们刚才闯了红灯。我可能跟丢了。他们闯了那个红灯，我看不出他们是往南上了明尼苏达大道，还是直走继续沿着宾夕法尼亚开了。
When Darren remembers his low speed chase, he thinks it took 20 minutes. Actually, from the time he made the call to the time he lost the trail, four minutes and ten seconds elapsed. The 911 woman gave him the address of the closest police precinct, which was one he just passed. Darren went in thinking the police had been breathlessly following his pursuit on the police band and would recognize him immediately. But they had no idea who he was. He made a second report of the same stolen car and went home.
当达伦回忆起这场低速追逐时，他以为花了20分钟。实际上，从他拨打电话到跟丢目标，只过了4分10秒。911接线员给了他最近警察局的地址，那正是他刚刚经过的一个。达伦走进去，以为警察一直在警察频道上屏息凝神地追踪他的追捕，会立刻认出他来。但他们根本不知道他是谁。他做了第二次关于同一辆被盗车的报案，然后回家了。
So the next thing, it's about 2:30 in the morning and my cell phone rings, and it's the police letting me know that they had indeed captured the guys and retrieved my car, and that my car was being towed to the city's tow lot for storage overnight.
接下来，大约凌晨2点半，我的手机响了，是警察打来的，通知我他们确实抓住了那些人，追回了我的车，而且我的车被拖到了市里的拖车场过夜寄存。
The police didn't give Darren much information about who'd stolen the car, why, or whether anyone had been arrested. But he got a few clues once the car came back to him because the thieves had left behind all sorts of stuff. In the trunk was a tool box with lots of expensive tools, including a blowtorch. There was a giant key ring with 50 or 60 keys on it, several of them master keys to different types of cars. There was a huge subwoofer and a leather case holding a vast collection of CDs, although not the kind of CDs that you usually associate with subwoofers.
警察没有给达伦提供太多关于谁偷了车、为什么偷，或者是否有人被捕的信息。但他还是在车回来后得到了一些线索，因为小偷在车里留下了各种各样的东西。后备箱里有一个工具箱，里面有许多昂贵的工具，包括一把喷灯。还有一串巨大的钥匙圈，上面有五六十把钥匙，其中几把是不同型号汽车的万能钥匙。有一个巨大的重低音炮和一个装着海量CD的皮包，虽然不是那种你通常与重低音炮联系在一起的CD。
The Indigo Girls, Lilith Fair, Tracy Chapman, The Dixie Chicks.
靛蓝女孩（Indigo Girls）、莉莉丝巡演（Lilith Fair）、翠西·查普曼（Tracy Chapman）、南方小鸡（The Dixie Chicks）。
I'm standing with Darren in a storage area in the back of his apartment where he still keeps a lot of the stuff that was left in his car. If the key ring and the loot in the trunk tell the story of professional thieves with tools and musical contraband, the other stuff tells a different story, a more domestic one.
我和达伦站在他公寓后面的储藏区，他仍保留着车里留下的大部分东西。如果那串钥匙和后备箱里的战利品讲述的是带有工具和音乐违禁品的职业盗贼的故事，那其他东西则讲述了另一个故事，一个更琐碎的家庭故事。
There was a couple of job applications in there, one of them was to Red Lobster and I don't know where the other ones were from. There was some tubes of Silly Putty, and there were some football sticker helmets, and then they had kids' toys in there. I kept one of the baby toys that they had in the car. It's a purple, round rattle, baby's rattle. They were definitely using the car to just go about their regular business.
里面有几份求职申请，其中一份是给红龙虾餐厅（Red Lobster）的，我不知道其他的是哪里的。还有几管橡皮泥，一些橄榄球贴纸头盔，然后还有孩子的玩具。我留下了他们车里的一个婴儿玩具，是一个紫色的圆铃，婴儿用的拨浪鼓。他们绝对是把车用在日常生活中。
It was hard not to imagine the car thief carting his kids around or pulling out the rattle if they started crying in the back seat. Or saying, I'm sick of jacking cars. I'd like to work in food service. One of the men left his voter ID in the car. He's a registered Democrat, 20 years old. Not that any of this made Darren feel any differently about these guys.
很难不去想象那个偷车贼带着他的孩子们转悠，或者如果孩子们在后座哭闹，他就拿出拨浪鼓来哄。或者说，“我厌倦了偷车，我想去餐饮服务业工作。”其中一人把选民身份证落在了车里。他是个20岁的登记民主党人。当然，这些并没有让达伦对这群人产生什么改观。
I was mostly angry that they had put 3,000 miles on my car and had put all sorts of crap in it and that they were using my car to go break into other cars.
我主要生气的是他们给我的车跑了3000英里，还往里塞了一堆垃圾，而且用我的车去破门入室偷窃其他车辆。
I found out the police had arrested the owner of the voter ID-- his last name is Martin-- while he was driving the car. But they dropped the case. Apparently, catching someone red-handed driving a stolen car isn't enough evidence to make his case go to trial. The person can just say he got the car from someone else. I made an ultimately unsuccessful attempt to find this Martin guy. First, I sent a letter to both the address on the arrest report and the one on the voter ID. I had some difficulty with the wording. There's just no Hallmark card that says, I think you stole my future brother-in-law's car. Let's talk.
我发现警察在那个选民身份证的主人——他姓马丁——驾驶那辆车时把他逮捕了。但他们撤诉了。显然，仅仅抓到某人现行驾驶被盗车辆，证据不足以让他被起诉。那个人完全可以说车是从别人手里拿来的。我最终做了一次不成功的尝试，试图找到这个马丁。首先，我寄信到逮捕报告上的地址和选民身份证上的地址。我在措辞上遇到了困难。根本没有任何贺卡写着：“我觉得你偷了我未来妹夫的车，我们谈谈吧。”
I started calling around to Red Lobsters in the area, hoping Martin had picked up another application. I also called various phone listings for men with Martin's first and last names. One day, a guy answered. He said he was the godbrother of the Martin I was looking for. After mulling over several options in my head, I said, I think Mr. Martin might have had some involvement with a car belonging to a friend of mine. There was a long silence. Finally, the man asked, why would I want to help you?
我开始给当地的红龙虾餐厅打电话，希望马丁能又投了一份申请。我还打了电话查询系统里所有姓马丁的名字。一天，有个男人接了电话。他说他是那个马丁的教父。在脑子里盘算了几种方案后，我说：“我觉得马丁先生可能和某个朋友的车有牵扯。”电话那头沉默了很久。最后，那个人问：“我为什么要帮你？”
Curtis Sittenfield. She has a novel called Prep.
柯蒂斯·西滕费尔德（Curtis Sittenfeld）。她有一本小说叫《预科（Prep）》。
Great News Tim is a salesman at Gillespie Chevrolet and Pontiac on the southside of Chicago. And the thing you should know about him is he's not their number one salesman. He's their number two salesman. Here's Tim.
好消息蒂姆是芝加哥南区吉莱斯皮雪佛兰和庞蒂亚克的一名销售员。关于他，你应该知道的是，他不是他们的头号销售员，他是二号。这是蒂姆。
I'm the number one salesmen at Gillespie, the number one salesman in the world, best salesman in Gillespie. The only one who sells more cars than me is the owner. And the only reason why is because I assist him in his sales.
我是吉莱斯皮的头号销售员，世界第一销售员，吉莱斯皮最棒的销售员。唯一比我卖车多的人是老板。而那唯一的原因是因为我协助他销售。
The number one salesman at Gillespie, sorry Tim, is actually a woman. Yvonne Hawk, the only woman on the sales staff of roughly 30 guys. And she's easily 20 years older than almost all of them, a grandmother. She sells 16 or so cars a month. The rest of the guys, except for Great News Tim, average around 10 or 11. But he's also got that Muhammad Ali thing going.
吉莱斯皮的头号销售员，抱歉蒂姆，其实是一位女士。伊冯·霍克，大约30个销售人员中唯一的女性。她比几乎所有人都大至少20岁，是一位祖母。她每个月卖出16辆左右的车。剩下的伙计们，除了好消息蒂姆，平均在10到11辆。但他身上有一种穆罕默德·阿里的气质。
No, I'm something like the greatest in his prime. That's me, Great News Tim, all day long.
不，我就像处于全盛时期的最强者。那就是我，好消息蒂姆，一整天都是。
So you said you were the number one sales guy, but isn't Yvonne number one?
所以你说你是头号销售员，但伊冯不是第一吗？
Look, I am the greatest. I mean, if you add up my sales and you divide it by the months that I've been selling, you'll see.
听着，我是最棒的。我的意思是，如果你把我的销售额加起来，除以我销售的月数，你就明白了。
Is Yvonne your biggest rival here?
伊冯是你这里最大的竞争对手吗？
I have no rivals.
我没有对手。
What's the first thing you say to someone when they walk in the door?
有人进门时，你说的第一句话是什么？
The first thing I do is I meet and greet the customer, and then I ask them something crazy like, are you here for the big sale? And usually they'll say, what big sale?
我做的第一件事是迎接顾客，然后我会问一些疯狂的问题，比如“你是来参加大促销的吗？”通常他们会说，“什么大促销？”
Is there any type of person where they walk in and you just go, I know my charm isn't the type of charm that's going to charm this person, and I'm just going to let it go?
有没有那种人，当他们走进来，你就会想：“我知道我的魅力不足以打动这个人，我就放过他吧？”
I could sell anybody. I sold a man who couldn't talk one day. Everybody who was walking up to this man and saying, hey sir, how are you doing? Are you here to purchase a car? And the man is hunching his shoulders. I walked up to the man and I hunch my shoulders. And then I pointed at a car and he was like, I pointed at another car. He shook is head to say, yeah. And I rubbed my fingers together as in, do you have money? And he was like, yeah. I said, let's go. I signed him up. So I sold a deaf and mute man a car. I sold a Chinese person cars, I've sold all types of people cars. I could call somebody on the phone, seriously, from the White Pages of the phone book, that's probably sitting at home on the couch eating cereal and sell them a car over the phone and they'll come in and purchase.
我可以卖给任何人。有一天我卖给了一个不会说话的人。当时每个人都走到那个人面前说：“嘿，先生，你好吗？你是来买车的吗？”那人只是耸耸肩。我走到他面前，我也耸了耸肩。然后我指向一辆车，他点点头，我又指向另一辆车，他摇头表示不是。我把手指搓了搓，示意“你有钱吗？”他点点头。我说：“走吧。”我签了他。所以我卖给了一个聋哑人一辆车。我卖给过中国人车，我卖给过各种人车。我可以认真地从电话簿里打给某个人，他们可能正坐在沙发上吃麦片，我就能通过电话把车卖给他们，然后他们就会进来买。
Could you sell me a car?
你能卖给我一辆车吗？
I sure could. Are you ready right now? Are you here for the big sale?
我绝对可以。你现在准备好了吗？你是来参加大促销的吗？
Gallup came out with a poll that ranked car salespeople the least trusted professionals in America. They scored lower than lawyers and members of Congress. Nurses were the most trusted, school teachers were second. And if you think about it, both those professions-- nurses and teachers-- are associated with women. Hence, I believe Yvonne's advantage in car sales over Great News Tim. He's the hard sell, he's testosterone. Yvonne, you just don't think she can rip you off. She looks and acts like your mother.
盖洛普民意测验将汽车销售员评为美国最不受信任的职业。他们的得分比律师和国会议员还低。护士是最受信任的，小学老师第二。如果你想想看，这两个职业——护士和老师——都与女性联系在一起。因此，我认为伊冯在汽车销售方面优于好消息蒂姆是有道理的。他是强行推销，是雄性激素。至于伊冯，你就是觉得她不可能坑你。她看起来和行为都像你的母亲。
In our very first conversation, she talked about her baby granddaughter, and I found myself confiding my fear of flying. I watched her cozy up to a middle aged lady in the showroom by complimenting her outfit, which was pretty great. Kind of runway meets lumberjack look, all in green. Then talking about dogs and kids. It's not exactly flirting she's doing, it's more like infiltrating. But in the nicest possible way.
在我们第一次谈话中，她提到了她的孙女，我发现自己居然向她坦白了我对飞行的恐惧。我看着她通过称赞一位中年女士的装束——那装束确实很棒，有点像T台模特碰上伐木工的风格，全身绿色——来拉近关系。接着又聊起了狗和孩子。她做的不仅仅是调情，这更像是渗透，但以一种尽可能亲切的方式。
Did you see our Gillespie key chains? We got nice, classy key chains.
你看过我们的吉莱斯皮钥匙链吗？我们有很棒、很有档次的钥匙链。
Oh yeah?
哦，真的吗？
Yes. Where's William? Hang on.
是的。威廉在哪里？等等。
William's the guy who brings the swag to customers at Gillespie.
威廉是那个在吉莱斯皮给顾客带纪念品的伙计。
William, to the showroom, please. Customer waiting. William, to the showroom.
威廉，请到展厅来。有顾客在等待。威廉，来展厅。
Is it real good, can I take it to the pawn shop?
这东西是真的好东西吗？我能带去当铺吗？
It looks like it is, but it ain't that good.
看起来是，但没那么值钱。
The guy she's getting the key chain for, Rob Walker, is a jail guard and deputy sheriff. A big guy, 255 pounds. But here in the showroom with Yvonne, he's a little sheepish. He's got messed up credit, he's worried about getting financing. He knows he can't get his dream car, a Cadillac Seville. But he walked in hoping he could at least get a truck of some kind. She's willing to help him out with the credit, but she lets him know he can't afford a truck, not right now. She encourages him to buy something smaller, make payments for a year, and then come back next December and she'll sell him that truck.
她要拿钥匙链给的那个男人，罗伯·沃克，是一名监狱守卫兼副警长。大块头，255磅重。但在展厅面对伊冯时，他有点害羞。他的信用记录很糟糕，担心贷款问题。他知道他买不起梦寐以求的凯迪拉克赛威。但他走进来时，希望至少能买到一辆皮卡。她愿意帮他处理贷款，但她让他明白他买不起皮卡，至少现在不行。她鼓励他买一辆小的，分期付款一年，明年十二月再回来，她就卖给他那辆皮卡。
They walk around the lot, but management doesn't let me go with them. Too sensitive for national broadcast. So they both tell me about it when they stroll back in.
他们在场地上转了一圈，但管理层不允许我跟着他们。这对全国广播来说太敏感了。所以当他们溜达回来时，他们俩都跟我说了过程。
When him and I went on the lot at first, it was certain cars that were out of his range. And so me and him did a little bouting. But I did it in a nice way so that he wouldn't feel bad that he couldn't afford those, because he can't right now.
当我和他刚到场地时，有些车超出了他的范围。所以我和他小小博弈了一下。但我用一种友好的方式，让他不会因为买不起那些车而感到难受，因为他现在确实买不起。
What were the cars he had his eye on at first when you went out there?
你们第一次出去时，他看中的是哪些车？
An LS.
一辆LS。
What's that?
那是什么？
That's the Lincoln.
林肯。
Oh man, I can really picture myself in that Lincoln. I didn't see it at first. And we walked the whole lot, and it was like it was calling me. So I looked over there, I'm like, whoa. Let's go check this out. So she's like, oh this is nice, this is nice. Leather seats, it had a sun roof and stuff. She looks, she says, oh no, it's got too many miles on it.
天哪，我真的能想象自己开着那辆林肯的样子。我一开始没看到它。我们走遍了整个场地，它就像在召唤我。所以我看过去，我就想，哇。去看看这个。她说，哦，这不错，这不错。真皮座椅，还有天窗之类的。她看了看，说，哦，不，它的里程数太高了。
It had 79,000 miles on it. OK, he travels to and from work and he's got a couple of kids that he picks up and takes to different things. How quickly is he going to be over 100,000 miles?
它跑了79000英里。好吧，他还要开车往返工作，还要带几个孩子去不同的地方。他很快就会超过10万英里了。
And she was like, well in my opinion, I wouldn't get it. I would go with something else that's got lower miles. And I was like, whoa. Because usually a salesperson will go, whatever you want. I felt good, I felt like, OK, yeah, she's probably going to disappoint me, but she's going to tell me the truth.
她说，嗯，以我的观点，我不会买它。我会选另一辆里程数更低的。我就想，哇。因为通常销售员会说，随你想要什么。我感觉很好，我想，噢，好吧，她可能会让我失望，但她是在说实话。
She reminded me of my mother or an auntie, how she told me that I shouldn't get the Lincoln. And most mothers and good aunties do things like that. They're going to tell you the truth. Just like an outfit you got on, that outfit is ugly. You shouldn't wear that outfit. You're going to be a little hurt, but at least you're not going to be out in public with an ugly outfit on.
她让我想起了我的母亲或阿姨，她告诉我我不该买那辆林肯的方式。大多数母亲和好阿姨都会这样做。她们会告诉你真相。就像你穿的这件衣服，这衣服很丑。你不该穿那件衣服。你会受点小打击，但至少你不会穿着丑衣服出现在公众场合。
Buckle up.
系好安全带。
Finally, Yvonne convinces him to test drive a used Chevy Impala. Not the sexiest car in the world, but it's got leather seats and a sunroof and low mileage, and he fits in it.
最后，伊冯说服他试驾了一辆二手雪佛兰Impala。不是世界上最性感的车，但它有真皮座椅、天窗、低里程，而且他坐着正好。
How do you like it, Mr. Walker?
沃克先生，你觉得它怎么样？
It's all right, it's all right.
还行，还行。
He's clearly not in love with this car, but that doesn't matter. It's not about the car.
他显然没爱上这辆车，但这不重要。这与车无关。
I know one thing. When I do come back, I'm definitely going to ask for you again when I upgrade. Like I said, I like the way you make me feel like I'm somebody. Other places I went to, credit not all A1, people treat you like you're a second-class citizen.
我知道一件事。当我回来升级时，我肯定会再次找你。就像我说的，我喜欢你让我觉得自己是个重要人物的方式。我去过其他地方，信用没那么好，人们把你当作二等公民对待。
Which you're not.
你并不是。
Now, if you're thinking that Yvonne is just some soft-hearted granny, it's time to talk price. She's asking $20,630 for the Impala, $2,000 more than the suggested dealer's price in the Blue Book and $7,000 more than what the dealer paid for the car if they paid Blue Book trade-in value. She's not one to flinch about that. If there's one thing she's known for at Gillespie besides selling a lot of cars, it's that she's tough. You don't want to cross her. Her coworkers tell me how she strongarms finance companies, how she yells at managers when she thinks they're slowing down a sale. Here are Will and K.C., two of the guys on the floor.
现在，如果你认为伊冯只是个软心肠的老奶奶，那该谈谈价格了。她为那辆Impala报价20630美元，比蓝皮书（Blue Book）建议的经销商价格高出2000美元，如果经销商是按蓝皮书的以旧换新价值支付的话，这比他们的进货价高出了7000美元。她在这一点上可不会退缩。如果说伊冯在吉莱斯皮除了卖很多车还以什么出名，那就是她很强硬。你可不想惹她。她的同事们告诉我她是如何强迫金融公司、如何在她认为管理层拖慢了销售时对他们大喊大叫。这是威尔和K.C.，地板上的两个伙计。
She's not afraid of nobody. She's not afraid of anyone, anyone at all. She has a wonderful personality. You can change [UNINTELLIGIBLE] [BLEEP] off.
她不怕任何人。她不怕任何人，任何一个人。她人品很好。你可以把[哔]惹毛。
I ask Rob if he's noticed this side of Yvonne. It turns out he has, and he's got a whole philosophy about people like this who are tough but nice.
我问罗伯是否注意到了伊冯这一面。结果他注意到了，而且他对这种外强中干、心地善良的人有一套完整的哲学。
An individual like that that's nice and trying to make sure that she treat you like you're a human being, I wouldn't mess with them in a negative way. Because a nice person-- such as yourself, you look like you're real nice and maybe somebody could push you to a certain degree, but I would hate for you to turn or her to turn into that evil person because there may not be no stopping. When you mess with a nice person or a person they call a pushover or lame or a geek or whatever, I've learned in my line of work, them the type of people you don't mess with. Not in a negative way. It's almost like messing with a short person. You just don't do it.
像那样善良，并努力确保把你当人看的个体，我不会以负面的方式惹她们。因为善良的人——就像你自己，看起来你人很好，也许有人会把你逼到某种程度，但我很讨厌看到你变成那个邪恶的人，因为可能就停不下来了。当你招惹一个善良的人，或者人们称之为软柿子、窝囊废、书呆子之类的人时，我在我的工作中学会了，那是你绝对不要去招惹的类型。不是以负面的方式。这就像招惹个矮子。你就是不要那么做。
You're saying I'm like a tinderbox. I could explode.
你是说我像个火药桶。我会爆炸。
I'm saying that if your guy do something that just push you to the edge, that he may be in serious trouble. He may actually see the devil. He may be able to tell someone in an interview like this, I honestly believe that there's such a thing as the devil, and I've seen it. And if anybody asks why, because I did something to my wife and my girlfriend, and I've seen the devil.
我是说如果有人把你逼到了边缘，他可能会有大麻烦。他可能会真地见到恶魔。他可能在这样的采访中告诉别人，我真诚地相信有恶魔这回事，而且我见过。如果有人问为什么，因为我对我老婆和女朋友做了什么事，我见过恶魔。
Given all that stuff about the devil, I ask about the price of the Impala, if he's going to challenge Yvonne.
鉴于关于恶魔的那些话，我问起Impala的价格，问他是否打算挑战伊冯。
Are you going to haggle for this a little bit?
你打算为这个稍微砍砍价吗？
I'm going to see, can I work a little magic, talk to her.
我看看，我能不能施展一点魔法，和她谈谈。
Soon, Yvonne comes back. She's carrying a contract. She slides it in front of Rob and points.
很快，伊冯回来了。她拿着合同。她把它推到罗伯面前并指了指。
This is the price.
这是价格。
$20,630.
20630美元。
Right. And then your tax and your plates and everything, and your down payment. And then this is what you'd be trying to finance.
没错。然后加上税、牌照费、一切费用，还有你的首付。这就是你要贷款的金额。
He signs. Doesn't haggle, doesn't say a word about the price. While he's waiting for his car to get cleaned up, Yvonne insists he eat some pizza that's been brought in. You've been here a long time, she says. You must be hungry. A woman comes through the dealership selling teddy bears. Rob buys one. I figure he's just being a nice dad getting his kids a present. But then he walks over to Yvonne, a person who has just sold him an Impala for $2,000 above Blue Book and gives it to her.
他签了。没有砍价，关于价格一言不发。当他等着车清理时，伊冯坚持让他吃点送来的披萨。她说，你在这儿待了很久了，你一定饿了。一个女人带着泰迪熊来到经销商处兜售。罗伯买了一个。我以为他只是作为一个好爸爸给孩子买礼物。但后来他走到伊冯面前，这个刚刚以比蓝皮书高出2000美元的价格卖给他一辆Impala的人，把泰迪熊送给了她。
I already have my biological mother, I have a stepmother. Can I consider you a mom?
我已经有亲生母亲了，还有继母。我可以把你当成妈妈吗？
I'll be part of your family, too. And I'd like that. I really would.
我也愿意成为你家庭的一部分。我很乐意。真的。
How about I ride by and say I'm going to buy you lunch.
我路过时说请你吃午饭怎么样？
People come by and people do that. They bring me flowers and stuff on my birthday, and I like that.
确实有人路过并那样做。我生日时他们会给我带花之类的，我喜欢那样。
This is something Yvonne has in common with Great News Tim. He says his customers love him. They bake him cakes, they bring him candy. But where Yvonne has him beat, the reason she's number one and he's number two, is that no one's ever going to call him Mom.
这是伊冯和好消息蒂姆的共同点。他说他的顾客爱他。他们为他烤蛋糕，给他带糖果。但伊冯胜过他的地方，也就是她为什么是第一而他是第二的原因，是没人会叫他“妈妈”。
Sarah Koenig is a producer on our program.
莎拉·凯尼格是我们节目的制作人。
It was an '84 station wagon, a Chevy station wagon. I loved it. It was my life. I felt so much better when I was driving. I can't tell you how much a car means to a person. You're young and you really don't realize that, but if you have to give up driving, you're going to miss it. Nobody, nobody can understand what it's like unless you go through it.
那是一辆84年的旅行车，雪佛兰旅行车。我爱它。它是我的命。开车时我感觉好多了。我没法告诉你车对一个人来说意味着什么。你还年轻，还没意识到，但如果你不得不放弃开车，你会想念它的。没人，没人能理解那是什么感觉，除非你亲自经历过。
And even now, believe it or not, parking is over here. I can look out the window in my bedroom and all the cars are parked underneath that window. And sometimes I forget that I don't have the car anymore. I go out there to look if my car is parked in the lot. Crazy, isn't it? I don't know, what am I going to do without a car?
甚至现在，信不信由你，停车场就在这边。我可以从卧室窗户往外看，所有的车都停在窗下。有时我会忘了我已经没有车了。我跑出去看看我的车是不是停在停车场。很疯，对吧？我不知道，没有车我该怎么办？
Which brings us to this story of an old man and his car. But to understand this story, first a little history about 1955. 1955 was a very good year for cars and a bad year for drivers. The '55 Chevy Bel Air came out and Corvette got a V8 engine. But James Dean died in his Porsche on the way to a car race in California. And the worst racing accident in history took place at Le Mans when Pierre Levegh-- Lucky Pierre-- crashed his Mercedes Benz on the front straight, killing 81 people. As the dead and maimed were carted away, Mercedes withdrew from the event and at the end of that season, quit motorsports altogether.
这引出了这个老人和他的车的故事。但要理解这个故事，先了解一点关于1955年的历史。1955年对汽车来说是极好的一年，对司机来说却很糟糕。55年款雪佛兰Bel Air问世，科尔维特装上了V8引擎。但詹姆斯·迪恩在去加州参加赛车的路上在保时捷里丧生。赛车史上最严重的事故发生在勒芒，当时皮埃尔·勒维——“幸运的皮埃尔”——驾驶他的奔驰在主直道上撞毁，造成81人死亡。当死伤者被运走时，奔驰退出了赛事，并在赛季末完全放弃了赛车运动。
One side effect of this, a British driver named Stirling Moss could no longer race the Mercedes that he had become world famous for driving just a month before when he set the course record-- it was never defeated-- in a road race in Italy called the Mille Miglia, the 1,000 Miles. Moss and his navigator, Denis Jenkinson, covered the distance in 10 hours, 7 minutes and 48 seconds, which meant basically traveling at 100 miles an hour for 10 hours through little villages and winding country roads running the length of Italy. It's considered one of the greatest driving achievements in history.
这带来的一个副作用是，一位叫斯特林·莫斯的英国车手无法再驾驶奔驰车了，而他一个月前才凭借驾驶这辆奔驰在全球名声大噪，当时他在意大利的一场名为“一千英里赛（Mille Miglia）”的公路赛中创下了赛道纪录——至今未被打破。莫斯和他的领航员丹尼斯·詹金森在10小时7分48秒内跑完了全程，这意味着基本上在意大利的乡间村庄和蜿蜒乡路上连续10小时以每小时100英里的速度行驶。这被认为是赛车史上最伟大的成就之一。
The car that Moss drove is nearly as famous as he is, a Mercedes Benz 300 SLR, this big, silver cad of a car with red numbers 722 on the sides. Moss and the 722 still keep in touch, appearing regularly together at racing events like ambassadors at large for Mercedes Benz. And recently, Dan Neil, the automotive critic for the Los Angeles Times, got a ride with Moss-- now Sir Stirling-- in the old 722.
莫斯驾驶的车和他本人一样出名，奔驰300 SLR，一辆巨大的银色汽车，两侧有红色数字722。莫斯和722至今仍保持联系，经常作为奔驰的形象大使一同出现在赛车活动中。最近，《洛杉矶时报》汽车评论员丹·尼尔，与莫斯爵士一同试驾了那辆老722。
Sir Stirling Moss and the Mercedes Benz 300 SLR number 722 have been going steady 50 years, long enough to make it a common law marriage. The car is an open-top version of the famous Mercedes Gullwing. These Mercedes postwar silver arrows were so called because of their shiny skins of electron and aeronautic metal lighter than aluminum. 2,000 pounds and over 300 horsepower, these cars were unbreakable.
斯特林·莫斯爵士和奔驰300 SLR 722号已经形影不离50年了，时间长到足以称之为事实婚姻。这辆车是著名的奔驰鸥翼车型的敞篷版。这些奔驰战后银箭之所以得名，是因为它们闪亮的电子合金车身比铝还要轻。2000磅重，超过300马力，这些车坚不可摧。
Then there's Sir Sterling. People say he was the first modern race car driver. He made his living at the wheel, he wasn't just an aristocrat playing with cars. He was tight with a quid. He was the first driver to take physical fitness seriously, unlike many of his competitors for whom racing was macho part and parcel with boozing and broading the night away. His career-defining moment, his life-defining moment, was the 1955 Mille Miglia win, an almost supernatural performance that came out of nowhere. The Mille Migla record Moss set in 1955-- 10 hours, 7 minutes and 48 seconds-- are numbers every good wheelhead knows by heart.
然后是斯特林爵士。人们说他是第一位现代赛车手。他靠驾驶维生，他不仅仅是个玩车的贵族。他很精明。他是第一位认真对待身体素质的车手，不像他的许多竞争对手，对他们来说赛车和酗酒、晚上鬼混是不可分割的。他职业生涯中最具决定性的时刻，也是他生命中最具决定性的时刻，就是1955年赢下一千英里赛，那是一场几乎超自然的表现。莫斯在1955年创下的一千英里赛记录——10小时7分48秒——是每个优秀车迷心中铭记的数字。
Now it's 2004. On a rainy morning in October, Mercedes flies a few automotive journalists out to Virginia International Raceway to test a new car, a 617 horsepower carbon fiber monster that they have named the SLR. Price tag, $452,000. To sell the idea that this car is heir to the great SLRs of Moss's time-- and by the way, I'm not buying it-- Mercedes brings Sir Stirling and the original 722 to give writers rides around the track. This is a little bit like getting Lindbergh to do some sightseeing in the Spirit of St. Louis.
现在是2004年。10月的一个雨天，奔驰邀请了几位汽车记者去弗吉尼亚国际赛道测试一辆新车，那是一个617马力的碳纤维怪兽，他们把它命名为SLR。价格标签，452000美元。为了销售这辆车是莫斯时代伟大SLR继承者的理念——顺便说一句，我不买账——奔驰带来了斯特林爵士和最初的722，带着记者在赛道上绕圈。这有点像让林德伯格驾驶“圣路易斯精神号”进行观光飞行。
I meet Sir Stirling at lunch. It's him, all right. His features have thickened with age and he is, at 75, no doubt about it an old man. He's a little hard of hearing, but still quite within his wits. He's dressed in a dark red turtleneck and a houndstooth jacket, every inch an English gentleman. When it's time to go out to the track, he rises slowly. An assistant brings a wheelchair around for him. Sir Stirling has recently had back surgery. At the track the handlers are busy priming the car. The 722 is a beautiful brute in perfect condition, like a sculpture of streaming mercury. Two bolsters, like camel humps, are fixed to the rear deck behind the driver and the passenger.
我在午餐时见到了斯特林爵士。没错，是他。他的面容随着年龄增长而发福，75岁的他，毫无疑问是个老人。他听力有点不好，但依然十分敏锐。他穿着深红色的高领毛衣和人字纹夹克，活脱脱一个英国绅士。当该去赛道时，他缓缓起身。助手推来了轮椅。斯特林爵士刚做过背部手术。在赛道上，工作人员正忙着给车做准备。722是一头完美的钢铁野兽，像是一尊流动的汞金属雕塑。车后的甲板上固定着两个像骆驼驼峰一样的垫子。
Sir Stirling arrives. The camera crews go nuts. He's wearing a pale blue, one-piece cotton driving suit, a white polo helmet, goggles, and Italian, crocheted string-back gloves with leather palms. This is what racers wore back in the day before fire resistant Nomex and Kevlar full-face helmets. The car has no doors. Two people help as Sir Stirling stiffly climbs a step stool and settles into the driver's seat.
斯特林爵士到了。摄影组疯狂了。他穿着一件淡蓝色棉质连体驾驶服，白色马球头盔，护目镜，意大利勾针编织的背面透气手套，皮革手掌。这就是当年赛车手穿的东西，在防火诺梅克斯面料和凯夫拉全盔普及之前。这车没门。在两个人的帮助下，斯特林爵士僵硬地爬上踏脚凳，坐进了驾驶座。
He pushes the starter button and the car comes alive with a snappish bark. Gray smoke jets from the massive exhaust pipes jutting from the car's right side. Then something wonderful happens. The hand fits the glove, the hammer hits the string, the old man disappears behind the goggles, and the racer emerges from beneath the helmet. The car seems to recognize him. Sir Stirling slips the clutch and roars off.
他按下启动按钮，车子发出短促的叫声活了过来。灰烟从车身右侧突出的巨大排气管中喷射而出。然后神奇的事情发生了。手套贴合了双手，锤头击中了弦，老人消失在护目镜后，赛车手从头盔下浮现。车似乎认出了他。斯特林爵士松开离合器，轰鸣而去。
Moss said many times he could not have won the Mille Migla without his navigator, Denis Jenkinson, the bearded and gnomish Jenks. Their secret weapon? The pair ran a reconnaissance lap of the race with Jenks recording every detail on a roll of paper, eventually 15 feet long. This he unrolled during the race, shouting course notes to Moss over the canonade of exhaust when Jenks wasn't busy throwing up. When the race was over, the pair took off their goggles. This is a classic image of motorsports, Their faces blackened with dirt and soot except around the eyes. They look like pandas.
莫斯曾多次表示，没有他的领航员丹尼斯·詹金森，那个留着胡子的侏儒，他不可能赢得一千英里赛。他们的秘密武器？两人在比赛前跑了一圈勘察，詹金森把每一个细节都记录在一卷最终长达15英尺的纸上。他在比赛中展开这卷纸，在震耳欲聋的排气声中向莫斯大喊课程笔记，当詹金森不忙着呕吐的时候。当比赛结束，两人脱下护目镜。这是赛车运动的经典形象，他们的脸被灰尘和煤烟染黑，除了眼睛周围。看起来像熊猫。
Moss brings the car around and it's my turn. I climb the step stool and carefully belt in. Because the engine is tipped over more than 50 degrees to the right, the transmission tunnel runs between Sir Stirling's legs, the accelerator and brake on one side and the clutch on the left. This would be damn awkward for most people, and I wonder if a man who can barely walk can mange. Oddly enough, though, Moss finds the straddling position more comfortable than a regular car. He sits astride the car as if it were a horse.
莫斯把车开了回来，轮到我了。我爬上踏脚凳，小心翼翼地系好安全带。因为引擎向右倾斜超过50度，变速箱隧道横穿在斯特林爵士的双腿之间，加速器和刹车在一边，离合器在左边。这对大多数人来说会非常尴尬，我怀疑一个几乎走不动路的人能否搞定。奇怪的是，莫斯发现这种跨骑姿势比普通车更舒服。他骑在车上就像骑马一样。
The handlers push the car to get it going. Moss flicks a bug from his goggles and tears off. We're on the course. The first thing I notice: Jenks didn't have much to hang onto. Its too loud to talk, so I sit in Jenks's seat and I watch Sir Stirling muscle the wheel. We're not going particularly fast, but the car would be a handful for civilians. It doesn't have power steering. To give drivers better leverage, the steering wheel is oversized, a big four spoke aluminum wheel with a wooden rim. Moss shuffles the wheel through his hands so that they are always in the same position, 3:00 and 9:00.
工作人员推着车让它动起来。莫斯拂去护目镜上的虫子，飞驰而去。我们在赛道上了。我注意到的第一件事：詹金森没多少地方可以抓。车内太吵没法交谈，所以我坐在詹金森的位置上，看着斯特林爵士操控方向盘。我们跑得并不特别快，但这辆车对平民来说很难驾驭。它没有动力转向。为了给驾驶员更好的杠杆作用，方向盘超大，是一个带木圈的四辐铝合金大轮盘。莫斯在手中转换方向盘，使双手总是保持在相同的位置，3点和9点钟方向。
He twists his right foot to cover the brake and gas pedal, to rev the engine while braking and downshifting to save wear and tear on the gearbox. I watch him work. What is it like to be so good at something that even old and crippled you're still better than nearly everyone else?
他扭动右脚来兼顾刹车和油门，在刹车和降挡时提高引擎转速，以节省变速箱磨损。我看着他操作。对一件事如此擅长，即使年老残疾，依然比几乎所有人都强，那是种什么样的感觉？
We reach the main straight. The wind starts to whistle. He points at the big white tachometer. Every time he changes gears-- the gearshift knob has Roman numerals on it-- he indicates the gear with his gloved right hand. Third, fourth, fifth. That's about 110 miles per hour at this RPM. Now we've arrived at our real destination. This is how fast Moss and the SLR were speeding across the roads of Tuscany and the plains of a Mille Romana a half century ago. This is the speed that partnered them in history, so one of them cannot be thought of without the other.
我们到达主直道。风开始呼啸。他指着那个巨大的白色转速表。每次他换挡——档位球头上有罗马数字——他都用戴着手套的右手指示档位。三档，四档，五档。在该转速下那是约时速110英里。现在我们到达了真正的目的地。这就是半个世纪前，莫斯和SLR在托斯卡纳的道路和罗马的一千英里平原上疾驰的速度。这就是将他们载入史册的速度，所以没有对方，就无法想到另一个。
Imagine the Italian countryside going by. It suddenly seems very fast. Tomorrow, the car will go back to the Mercedes museum in Stuttgart, Sir Stirling to his house in Florida. We thread through a few more turns, then he wheels the silver car back to the pits. My rendezvous with history is concluded. I thank him and give the car a pat on the dashboard. And then the two of them roar off.
想象一下意大利的乡村掠过。它突然变得非常快。明天，这辆车将回到斯图加特的奔驰博物馆，斯特林爵士将回到他在佛罗里达的家。我们穿过几个弯道，然后他把这辆银色汽车转回维修站。我和历史的邂逅结束了。我感谢他，拍了拍车仪表盘。然后他们轰鸣而去。
Dan Neil is the automotive critic of the Los Angeles Times.
丹·尼尔，《洛杉矶时报》汽车评论员。
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder, Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Thea Chaloner and Chris Ladd.
今天的节目由莎拉·凯尼格和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯、艾米·欧莱利和丽莎·波拉克参与。高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德，伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责网站。托德·巴赫曼、西娅·查洛纳和克里斯·拉德提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOLWEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to any of our programs for absolutely free or buy CDs of them. Or you know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们的任何节目或购买CD。或者你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天节目的归档。本节目由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Torey Malatia, who is a winner, who is number one, and who has just one question for you.
WBEZ节目管理监管托里·马拉蒂亚，他是一个胜者，他是头号人物，他刚才有一个问题问你。
Are you here for the big sale?
你是来参加大促销的吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week for more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间回来收听更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。